el hobbit 19 avanza sin freno en brásil
la presencia de nuevas variantes en los
sistemas sanitarios al borde del colapso
y la lenta vacunación conforman un
cóctel peligroso que elevó las alertas
en la organización mundial de la salud
the situation in the air' y si ves la
situación es muy seria y estamos muy
preocupados brasil debería tomar medidas
de salud pública agresivas mientras
sigue distribuyendo las vacunas was also
rolling out
back sings este panorama llevó a
gobiernos como los de rio y sao paulo a
reinstaurar restricciones una medida
cuestionada por el presidente de jair
bolsonaro que el jueves instó a los
brasileños a dejar de llorar y quejarse
horas después bajo el tono pero repitió
las críticas a la política salvaje de
cerrar todo de nuevo no será buena
sabemos que el virus mata lamentamos las
muertes vamos a cuidar de las personas
el mandatario prometió la llegada de más
dosis de la vacuna para acelerar una
campaña que avanza de manera lenta e
irregular y sólo ha alcanzado al 35 por
ciento de la población
por eso la desesperación
y llevó a miles de adultos mayores a
hacer largas filas para conseguir la
inyección en esta ciudad del estado de
río de janeiro a pesar de que no cuenta
con dosis suficientes estoy aquí desde
las 4 de la mañana es absurdo un más
visión hay personas que durmieron en la
fila la segunda hora se vio agravada en
el país por la presencia de variantes
más transmisibles y peligrosas que
llevaron las cifras de contagios y
fallecimientos a los peores niveles
desde el inicio de la pandemia según el
equipo de respuesta del gobierno
brasileño el promedio de los últimos 14
días es de 1.250 decesos por día y
podría llegar hasta 3000 si no se
adoptan medidas serias para detener la
propagación del virus